Ana: Si el episodio anterior fue sobre café, códigos y ferrocarril, hoy entramos en una pregunta íntima: ¿quién ordena la vida de las personas, la Iglesia o el Estado?
Mateo: Esa es la pregunta central del conflicto Iglesia-Estado. Durante la colonia y buena parte del siglo XIX, la Iglesia administraba mucho más que culto: educación, cementerios, registros de nacimiento, matrimonio y muerte, además de influencia moral.
Ana: El liberalismo mira esa presencia y la interpreta como obstáculo para modernizar. No necesariamente quiere borrar la religión popular, pero sí separar efectos jurídicos de autoridad eclesiástica.
Mateo: Las reformas de 1884 son el punto fuerte: expulsión de jesuitas, cementerios laicos, matrimonio civil, divorcio o separación según el alcance histórico que debe verificarse, y supresión del fuero eclesiástico en materias civiles y penales.
Ana: Me llama la atención el cementerio laico. Parece un detalle administrativo, pero es profundamente simbólico: incluso la muerte deja de estar jurídicamente administrada por la Iglesia.
Mateo: Y el matrimonio civil tiene una potencia enorme. El Estado dice: para efectos jurídicos, familia, herencia, filiación y obligaciones no dependen del sacramento, sino de un acto reconocido por la ley civil.
Ana: Eso toca el corazón de la vida cotidiana. No es una reforma abstracta de gabinete; cambia cómo la gente nace jurídicamente, se casa, se divorcia, muere y aparece en registros públicos.
Mateo: Por eso hubo reacción católica. El obispo Bernardo Augusto Thiel fue expulsado; hubo resistencia, peticiones, amenazas de excomunión. Pero Costa Rica no terminó en guerra religiosa como otros países.
Ana: Ahí aparece otra vez el estilo costarricense: conflicto fuerte, sí; violencia total, no. Las tensiones se tramitan dentro de canales institucionales, con heridas, pero sin colapso del orden político.
Mateo: La educación es el segundo gran campo. La Ley General de Educación Común de 1886, impulsada por Mauro Fernández, establece primaria gratuita, obligatoria y laica para niños y niñas.
Ana: Eso es revolucionario en sentido institucional. Enseñar a leer y escribir no era solo una política social; era crear ciudadanos capaces de habitar una república de leyes.
Mateo: Y también centraliza. El Estado asume formación de maestros, supervisión escolar y financiamiento. La educación deja de depender de iniciativas dispersas y se convierte en política pública nacional.
Ana: Las escuelas normales profesionalizan la docencia. Me gusta pensar que ahí el Estado liberal no solo construye edificios, sino una tecnología moral: maestros, currículo, disciplina, ciudadanía.
Mateo: La paradoja es que el Estado sigue confesional en la Constitución de 1871, con catolicismo como religión del Estado, pero opera cada vez más como Estado laico de facto.
Ana: Esa distinción es muy costarricense: el texto constitucional conserva una fórmula tradicional, mientras la práctica administrativa avanza hacia registros civiles, escuela laica y tribunales civiles.
Mateo: La Iglesia pierde jurisdicción y bienes, pero no pierde influencia social. Más adelante volverá al centro político por otra vía: el catolicismo social y el socialcristianismo.
Ana: Entonces la secularización no es simplemente victoria liberal sobre religión. Es reorganización de competencias: qué corresponde a conciencia, qué corresponde al Estado, qué produce efectos jurídicos.
Mateo: Y deja una semilla decisiva: una ciudadanía educada por el Estado será capaz de exigir derechos al Estado. La escuela liberal, sin proponérselo del todo, prepara el terreno para la democracia social del siglo XX.